diana is with us in Des Moines Iowa
hi Diana how are you oh thank you I'm
fantastic thank you so much for taking
my call sure I have I will get my
masters in October and before that I'd
been looking for interviews and I you
know I I go and try to get a job an
internship anything from anywhere just
getting myself out there and I would get
the interviews I would go and I wouldn't
ever get the job and finally I was just
frustrated say oh I what am I missing
what am I not doing am i lacking
something you know and I I just finally
asked them to be honest with me and why
I'm not getting these jobs and she
finally one recruiter came back and said
will you have a horrific credit score
and to her she said a good credit score
equals a good employee and I just wanted
your thoughts on that or what am I doing
wrong am i looking at the wrong
businesses and what where I should go in
one place cool IRA maybe 600 I cut up
all my credit cards and closed all my
accounts so it dropped down okay you
closed all the accounts but you have
outstanding debt somewhere correct yep I
do still have outstanding that yes are
you behind on that or is it in default
no nope I'm not in behind I make the
monthly payments every every month and
then I'm on baby step 2
so I attack the smallest one first and
then a recruiter who says that a good
credit score equals a good employee and
if you don't have a good credit score
you could not possibly be a good
employee is too stupid to work for thank
you okay
like that's absurd person well you're
not a bad person obviously now now what
you do need to do is if your that's
someone in a hike in a corporate
environment is someone that's looking at
that a small business wouldn't pull your
credit bureau report and by the way 67%
of all people in America work for small
business okay that's businesses 500
people in under it's almost 7 out of 10
people work for people like that they
actually use freaking common sense or
Corporate America that are doofuses okay
because if somebody won't hire you when
you're current on your bills oh and
everything else looks good the interview
goes well and the only thing they use is
they go all your credit score we can't
hire you they're too stupid to work for
okay and so you've got but now what you
do may want to do is if you're going
into a place like that just do a
preemptive strike and go hey if you pull
my credit you may see it's a little low
because I'm on my way getting out of
debt and I closed all my accounts but
I'm current and I'm very fiscally
responsible and I can show you exactly
what I'm doing if you ever wanted to
know but if you're actually going to not
hire me based only on the credit score
we don't need to do an interview because
you're too stupid to work for a
preemptive strike like that and it'll
help you this is the Dave Ramsey show
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]